l'a400 droits sont renversés la grève
sauvage général mai 68 la plus grande
grève de l'histoire de france
le plus célèbre des mouvements sociaux
un mois d'émeutes et de révolte qui ont
fait vaciller le pouvoir
il semble bien que la contestation dans
l'université de paris s'oriente plutôt
vers la violence que vers la dialectique
c'est
ça c'est toutes les photos du mouvement
romain goupil a tout conservé de cette
période
photos films coupures de presse des
souvenirs personnels et garon 68
il est au coeur de l'événement à la tête
du mouvement lycéen
et après on est tous à la sorbonne donc
on va déclencher des premières paris iv
des premiers pavés et là c'est nous
c'est les lycéens en 1068 il n'a que 16
ans mais il est déjà très politisée ce
qui lui vaudra d'ailleurs d'être expulsé
de son lycée
disciple de trotski il rêve pour la
france d'une révolution bolchévique nous
tout jeune 16 ans 17 ans les lycéens où
on a vraiment l'impression l'illusion
que tout ce qu'on avait appris lui était
en train de se produire devant nous
l'histoire était en train de se faire
donc tournés sur un modèle de 1917 de la
révolution d'octobre fils de cinéaste
romain goupil manipule la pellicule dès
son plus jeune âge il apporte une caméra
partout où il va et tournent tous les
rassemblements politiques les
manifestations
il en tirera plus tard un film sur ses
années de jeunes militants
mourir à 30 ans j'avais toujours ma
petite caméra et pendant les moments où
je ne prenais pas la parole je filmais
7ème et 68 des barricades
les voitures en feu les pavés les
immenses manifestations d'étudiants crs
ss harry en feu nous on participait
parce qu'on n'était mis au service
d'ordre dans l'avant-garde avec des
casques heureusement qu'il y avait les
manifs les discussions s'arrêtait
c'était les bagarres laventure je
retrouvais mes deux anciens copains
coyotes et baptiste on s'amusait
notre 68 était très beau c'était avec
ces bagarreurs ses militants des types
qui était on n'était pas tendre du tout
c'est l'affrontement
[Musique]
à
boulevard saint germain à l'épave et de
l'autre vol jeudi chief ouvertement que
le pouvoir est entièrement responsable
de ce qui se passe sur les barricades
le jeune romain goupil au toit les
leaders du mouvement de mai 68 daniel
cohn bendit et à la gsma
jeudi soir le quartier latin allait être
une fois encore le théâtre de violents
désordres
malgré les appels à la discipline lancé
par l'un des smart les enragés
n'hésiterait pas à franchir le no man's
land séparant les manifestants des
forces de l'ordre en 1068 à la jeunesse
marc est un jeune professeur
d'université à la tête d'un syndicat
d'enseignants il se reconnaît totalement
dans les demandes des étudiants
well sentiment que la vieille université
était en train de mourir a recueilli
dont ces comportements archaïques non
ces programmes orgueil dans ses moyens
de contrôle de connaissances des
étudiants enfin tout était complètement
vermoulu aux manifestations des
étudiants qui demandaient plus de
liberté la réforme de l'université et
l'accès au dortoir des filles se
joignent bientôt les ouvriers ceux de
renault et de citroën
la grève se généralise et paralyse le
pays
les graffitis et affiche sommes tous les
murs les slogans tous plus inventifs les
autres les autres passeront à l'histoire
crs ss sous les pavés la plage
il est interdit d'interdire une période
d'effervescence à plein d'égards mai 68
a été un moment de cristallisation de
plusieurs mouvements en même temps
qu'ils se seraient produits probablement
de feu font à peu près inévitable
terrain la jeunesse aspirons à tout à
fait autre chose que leurs parents dans
la libération d'un pan de la pensée de
la parole de la vie
sexuelle de la musique de
que sais-je encore il se trouve que tout
ça a cristallisé sur un esma un espace
de temps extrêmement court
c'est ça qui fait mai 68 un très grand
symbole partisans de mao en 68 allégé
smara d'y échanger jusqu'à voter macron
aux dernières élections du camp romain
goupil et daniel cohn bendit qui a
activement fait campagne pour le nouveau
président français
à écouter j'avais 23 ans maintenant et
73,6 entre ce 23 ans et 73 g pas changer
ça cesse et dangereux oui évidemment que
j'ai changé
romain goupil lui a misé au vestiaire
ses idées révolutionnaires
dès 1973 devenu libertaire et
écologistes il est soulagé que ces idées
radicales de jeunesse ne se soit pas
imposer cela des fêtes dépassent toutes
mes espérances
heureusement qu'on n'a pas gagné on
aurait tous finis ou en prison comme en
italie ou mort comme en allemagne
et tout ça pour le gaspiller
complètement l'énergie entière de toute
une génération c'est absurde c'est pas
parce qu'on s'est trompé sur l'analyse
qu'il fallait entraîner tout le monde
sur cette erreur révolutionnaire
heureusement il ya une récupération dans
la société
la société a récupéré tout ce qui
s'était passé en 68 et c'est peut-être
dans ce sens là on peut dire qu'il ya
déjà qui ya dans des tas de domaines un
avant et un après je suis pas sur danic
on fêtera le 100e anniversaire en sorte
bon et moi je ne peux pas être 50 donc
on pourra faire suivre donc
les ancien leader de mai 68 ne souhaite
pas que le 50e anniversaire donne lieu à
de grandes commémorations
tout au plus quelques tables rondes et
causerie pour décortiquer ensemble le
passé 68 sas a ouvert d'état port mais
on a mis du temps enfermé romain goupil
et daniel cohn bendit eux sont devenus
de grands amis 6 mai 68 ne représentent
aujourd'hui plus grand chose dans leur
vie ils restent fiers de ce que le
mouvement a accompli les avancées de 68
son mondial et existe encore maintenant
la vraie victoire de 68
c'est la société civile mais des femmes
c'est les mouvements féministes qui vont
imposer la liberté de l'avortement 75
imposé de renoncer à toutes les lois
inégalitaire
ne pas disparaître après paris le monde
entier
de mai 68 les restes aussi bien sur le
mythe la légende l'euphorie de l'époque
raconté par les soixante huitards à
leurs enfants aient la conviction encore
aujourd'hui en france une manifestation
pu tout changer
car sous les pavés il y à la plage
[Musique]
à